I see a fifth or six seed team who will
at best make it to the second round
we are the new kings of the East this
again didn't we do this last year I
defend anyone said LeBron will take the
horse word of no book he says he's not a
foster oh he's a bustle run there will
be a new
[Music]
but why must you leave I'm a free agent
now will you be back I one way or
another but but where will you go I'll
raise the sails in me heart and let the
winds of Destiny blow were like you're
wearing a lakers clinic well yeah hope
you realize how sneakers are bad right
Ross in my ears have come to accept that
I'll lose in the playoffs no matter
where I go but Los Angeles has a beach
right well I must be going through onion
seasons upon us come on now Russ don't
worry I'm not gonna go anywhere
kind of like that each district
you're wondering why I brought you all
here after all we just had a feast to
celebrate our number one seed and since
when does old Drake give two feasts in a
single fortnight well it's no good being
Lord of the six if you can't celebrate a
first-round victory with heroes the
great Knights house Raptors sure the
scribes they don't want to talk about us
some dingy house in the north they all
just want to talk about the process and
the washed up King LeBron
and I say LeBron can have his stupid
feast this year the North will feast on
the east first a toast
no more that southern horse piss proper
wine for proper nights
courtesy of your champagne
puppy stand together no over everything
[Music]
are you not wasting good wine on a damn
horse
yeah to the men who slaughtered the
Wizards in only six games yes yes
cheer brave men all of you took six
games to be the house that had three
less wins this year than the Nuggets
haven't you little northern nice killing
paws means nothing if you can't fell the
king
am i dying no we're just joking you get
used to it
when people ask you what happened here
tell them King James still rules the
east also tell them I'm better than
Michael Jordan
King James has slaughtered the Raptors
in four battles but I thought the
Messiah Ujiri could walk on water trades
would be George King then conquered
bostonia after grueling seven bottles
I'm stealing is still lower than false
what's this Bryan Colangelo was dumb and
his collars are too big oh thank you
Honest Abe Bryan you know when my wife
decided to raise the burner Ravens I had
my doubts but I've really grown to love
you all
even you little jacob Reuben Oh filler
one two three four five six seven
did someone mention me you will Lord
Hinke is better and smarter than you
Eric Junior Eric Junior what's this the
Curious Case of Bryan long collars a
busy mace the Dietrich of the ringer
Gilda's published a paper accusing you
of using federal agents is this true
what no that's ridiculous sorry honesty
where is he getting all this some
analytics where's that did it analysis
of the scrolls analytics wizard No
[Music]
that you Lord Ange
Gordon another late night of board
gaming huh all right Terry I think maybe
you're taking the scary thing a bit too
far now
nice what are you doing here
[Music]